Ben Affleck you makes it more circles I
do I have some experience with the
Royals actually I hadn't any experience
with the Royals or royalty we just went
to we and I took like I said took the
kids to Windsor Castle we went to
Windsor Castle we went we saw the Tower
of London we thought everywhere that the
Royals go and live and have you know cut
each other's head off over history but I
took my my youngest son to you know kid
neighs iam you know that place it's like
when it's raining outside indoor why
should play and they have to you know
germy balls that they exactly and so I
went in there and it was pretty empty
and then and then I noticed like you
have this sort of weird vibe from some
of the other grown-ups that were there
and I sort of look around they're all
really well-dressed suits on you know
and I saw that some of them had had
pieces in and I thought wow Museum is
tight I was the last person in there for
sure to realize that the the Royal Gorge
and Charlie yes the those kids were in
there playing and my son was in there
playing so now I can tell him like you
got a cold from the king of England
[Laughter]
[Music]
you